on December 6th 2017 the Google acquired
company specializing in machine learning
known as deep mine put their chest
software alpha0 up against the world's
strongest chess engine stock fish and
this was game 3
we start with Knight f3 and one thing
that we're gonna note throughout this
entire video series this match that
we're covering between alpha zero and
stock fish is that alpha zero seemed to
take a surprisingly human or we'll call
it positional chess approach against the
world's deepest and fastest calculator
we have a queen's indian here on the
table we're gonna talk about just how
deep the theory went between these two
Mecca machines here after Queen to c2 c5
and d5 we see a very well known
positional pawn sacrifice in the Queen's
Indian White's idea is that by giving up
the d5 pawn black is going to struggle
from there on out to deal with the
potential pressure along the D file
combine that with the fact that black
has to lose a bit of time in order to
safely take this d5 pawn we're treating
this Bishop to the diagonal that it
didn't originally develop to is one of
the key ideas behind white's line here
for example after each takes d5 C takes
capturing the pawn immediately is not an
option for black due to Queenie
forecheck which will either win the
knight or win the rook on a8 after black
retreats the knight to e7
so of course stockfish is not gonna fall
for that and rather than taking the pawn
on d5 after bishop the bishop backs up
to b7 white plays Bishop to g2 now we
can safely take on d5 castles Knight to
c6 rook to d1 and Bishop e7 this game is
all theory it played many times by
grandmasters and amateur chess players
of all levels Bishop to e7 pointing out
the fact that white cannot safely take
this this piece on d5 due tonight to
before so in case you're wondering just
how many blunders are these computers
gonna make out of the opening they are
not actually making blunders just yet so
after Bishop e7 white of course does not
take and instead plays the move Queen a5
again still following theory and White's
goal over the next series of moves is to
try to coordinate the pieces in such a
way that the D file and potentially the
Queen side pieces will not be well
coordinated in
order to prevent white from developing
compensation over on this side of the
board particularly the kingside and
maybe a long-term King side attack this
is again the common theme behind this
positional sacrifice of the d5 pawn in
the Queen's Indian but again this is not
necessarily news especially to our
advanced players after efore again
you're just trying to anchor in the
potential weaknesses here on d5 and d6
g6 queen of four castles ePHI all theory
all played many times after Knight to h5
Queen to g4
the move rook to e8 is officially our
first novelty quote-unquote played by
stockfish moves that have been played
previously include numerous Queen
maneuvers Queen to b8 a move that gets
the Queen off the D file tries to put
pressure on the pawn here Queen to c8
also getting the Queen off the D file
and trying to avoid moves like rook
takes d7 with a whole lot of fun the
move that had been played most commonly
is to move d5 in this position now
interesting that stockfish didn't play
the move that has been played by a von
Chuck and other strong grandmasters
after d5 one of the most well known
games is e takes d6
Bishop to f6 and after the move Knight
to c3 speaking of a von Schuch he played
the move Knight to d4 against Magnus
Carlsen at the amber blindfold and rapid
chess festival back in 2007 but after
Knight takes d4 Bishop takes G to Magnus
surprised with the interesting idea
Knight f5 not capturing back on g2 but
putting the knight on f5 and keeping
this long-term compensation of the D
pawn magnus went on to win a very nice
game against a von chuck so maybe alpha
0 or stockfish were both studying up on
this line and decided not to go for it
Bishop takes d6 is also a move of course
after d5 but after Knight c3 Queen b8 I
quoted a game here by Wayne you where
after Queen a4 and Knight to d5 he went
on to win also in a nice attacking
fashion against John rouse and another
grandmaster so those are just a couple
games to give you some context in
regards to the type of game that can
happen here we're white even at the end
of lines like this as you can see
White's down upon but the compensation
is based on a number of long-term
factors lack of coordination of the
pieces on the Queen side potential
attacking chances against all of the
darks
on the kingside and again just overall
white having a more active pressure
being exerted on the position and again
these are these are the types of words
if you listen to the semantics that I'm
saying that are almost describing
abstract types of compensation and
features of the position and as we dive
into these games here by alpha 0 against
stockfish we're gonna see that this is a
common theme that your shrew who has
pretty much spent the last 48 hours
obsessed with these games I've noticed
about alpha zeros approach his
willingness to play for long term
compensation and sacrifice material
something that we've been waiting for
computers or let's say machine learning
to understand and the way the humans do
so really fascinating rikiei played by
stockfish of course a great move now
after Knight to c3 note that taking on
d7 likely met by moves like Queen to c8
and the point is that this is just this
is not a fun thing for white to deal
with now so obviously it's something
that we think about with white having
compensation on the D file in the way
that I've highlighted but it's not
something that white is necessarily
threatening so after Knight c3 Queen DBA
was played and and this is where you
first start to feel that stockfish is
losing the threat on this position not
that Queen BA trying to hit a 5 is a bad
idea or that rook e8 is really a bad
novelty as compared to d5 and the moves
that I highlighted the Devon shock or
rouse and another's plate but then after
Queen b8 you're sort of bluffing at
taking this pawn and alpha zero just
goes forward with the move Knight to d5
of course taking me five is just not
possible due to the fact that Y can
capture and take on e7 and in the end
Bob's your uncle with the with a bishop
hanging on b7 so Knight to d5 is played
that means that black has to save the
dark squared bishop and after Bishop
before you suddenly see again that
stockfish just doesn't like the last
couple moves he played now with the
Queen on b8 there's threats of moves
like e6000 Intermezzo of course white is
gonna play Knight f6 check not just take
back the pony and and that's the reason
why this Knight as bad as it is on the
edge and you love to trade it is sort of
froze into this square because of the
weaknesses on the dark squares that
we've been highlighting are going to be
a common theme
so after Bishop afford the stockfish
play queen c8 but here come the natural
series of moves developing pressure on
the King
side that leads to alpha zero getting a
very very clean-looking attack the move
rook to d6 is coming followed by rook to
f6 this seems odd at first but again if
you highlight the fact that not thinking
the way humans do these are just a bunch
of positional weaknesses without really
any concrete ability to get rid of that
rook who's now lodged himself on f6 so
why not put a rook on f6 let the other
rook do the dirty work on the D file and
again to continue to try to pry open the
King's side this is kind of the the way
that alpha zero looks at this position
we get a trade and the other one comes
to d1 as we've highlighted ninety-six
another trade no problem if you're alpha
zero and as soon as the Queen lodges
herself on h6 we're gonna see the
natural plan that we've talked about
only a matter of time that was gonna
come which is why it's gonna start
pushing forward on the Kings side one
thing that's interesting is you see that
stock fishes approach over the last
several moves where the way stock fish
would like to play a lot of positions
saying I've up a pawn I have material
that's that's a good thing right that's
how I've been taught by human beings to
think about chess but apparently alpha
zero being allowed to do machine
learning organically on his own has
better ideas of what the long-term
compensation is what I'm saying is that
white is white is still in a very
controlling position on the board to
attack despite the fact that stock fish
feels that he's coordinated held on to
his extra pawn and actually traded off
pieces you're not supposed to be able to
get a really great mating attack when
there's not that many minor pieces left
on the board but the point is that if
you look at this position from the other
angle it almost reminds you of short
Timman where yes black has been able to
trade off some of the minor piece
pressure with the Knights coming off the
board and yes black is still up that
pawn but the main thing is that white
controls all the cards you almost wish
that this king could go on some kind of
journey and pop itself on f6 and will
get a mate on g7 all out of the game I
talked about was short and timid but
that's not one that's not gonna happen
here but to the point is I'm just
reminding us of that really legendary
game just Google short Tim and King walk
if you haven't seen that amazing game
and you'll see it just to highlight the
fact that black is frozen so it's not so
much that black has been able to
simplify and liquidate pressure the
problem is black is really not able to
do anything really at this point stock
fish is begging white to take the D pawn
because if white had taken the D pawn
instead of that now you'll see rook da
and black will start to get the
compensation that he wants to get in
this type of game or or get the freedom
that he needs if the D pawn disappears
of course also moves like Queen a4 Queen
takes a2 and other ideas would be
another reason why white might
eventually regret opening the D file
just to note but I was just sort of
highlighting the key idea there that
white doesn't want to take it so after
h4 Queen a5 the threat there everybody
was to move Queen e1 check followed by
take c5 so of course alpha 0 not
interested now after c-4 renewing the
threat of the Queen gobbling up the e5
pawn alpha 0 remains in in the driver's
seat here by refusing for the position
to change Queen check King g2 now stock
fits just the best he can to create
counter play and if you look at the
evaluation bar to the left of our board
you'll see that stock refers still
feeling comfortable that of course is
the evaluation of the world's former
maybe strongest chess engine still
feeling like black is doing ok here you
give it more time to think it does think
white has compensation but really if you
look at this from a human perspective
and knowing what how this game went we
already feel like white is almost
totally winning here not just a little
advantage after h5 black still has a lot
of a lot of a lot to do about nothing
lack of options black is gonna sit tight
with rookie 7 now that we've got
pressure on the squared g6 you're gonna
see why try to maneuver to create
tactical opportunities with this Bishop
popping back and forth potentially to
these two diagonals working with the
rook and Queen together over there the
bishop comes to d1 now comes to be free
and after the move rook to d8 rook F
free this is when things start to get a
little fun and we we're gonna we're
gonna highlight that after the move
Queen e4 Queen d2 if you're stock fish
there you want to start looking for ways
to activate because we start to see the
writing on the wall white wants the pawn
on h6 these rooks are gonna be frozen if
they ever move the d7 pawn might fall
which of course opens up everybody and
their cousin for a party on f7
plus if h6 is established then you know
this King is gonna have long term back
rank issues so what what about a move
like Knight c5 here for black would that
have helped to try to eliminate this
LightSquared Bishop and hit the e5 pawn
well after H takes g6 H takes g6 we
start to see some really really amazing
lines here starting with the move Queen
to g5 hit
Brooke on e 7 and highlighting why this
night should have never have left East
6th if Knight takes b3 we'll just
highlight that just in case you're
wondering why it's just taking on e7 and
there's no time for black to try to
gobble and stay equal because white is
winning this rook let's check followed
by taking back the knight here why it's
gonna be up a whole rook so that's not
an option and that means after Queens g5
you're gonna have to protect this rook
on e8 but now this with the rook swings
from d4 over to h4 and a mating net will
ensue unless black is willing to play
for some sort of endgame like Queen
takes e5 but here white would just go
and win the exchange and go on to win an
endgame easily so that's an example of
where black is is really tough right
again it seems solid but like really is
lacking moves here so after Queen a g4
which was played the bishop came back to
d1 the Queen came back to e4 white
establishes this pawn on h6 it's really
a grind here alpha zero is gripping that
King's side to eventually put black in a
position where he has even less moves
than he's currently had with all the
Queen's shuffling right we're hoping to
get black in a position where he's
running out of squares altogether Knight
to c7 makes sense and after rook d6
again the first thing we have to look at
is why didn't stock fish just take the
pawn first rook takes is off the table
because if the d7 pawn Paul's now that
the h6 Square has h6 pawn excuse me has
taken away the g7 square the back rank
mating nets are gonna be too much for
black to deal with Queen takes d5 is the
other option but we're gonna see a
really fun common theme here that white
could have skewered followed by F 4 and
this Queen is simply overworked unable
to deal with the rook on e7 so after 96
and rook to d6 I'm sorry after after
knight Knight back to c7 and then the
rook came to d6 that's why that poem was
untaken ball so black comes right back
we have to continue to prevent this
threat of queen to g5 that's what
stockfish is trying to do but here the
bishop comes back to b3 and we see a
position that's very similar to what we
had just a few moves ago but the
improvements for white are on the board
this pawn is no longer on h5 it's on h6
black still can't really touch any of
these pawns or do anything to free up
the D file and with these new open lines
created white is white is even more in
the kind of I will call it the BOA
stricter position black takes the pawn
on e5 and that would be maybe what stock
fishes plan was all along not realizing
the
to alpha zero this really is only gonna
help white get more pressure but after
takes rook d5 Queen h8 here's here's
where the gloves start to come up this
Queen gets the diagonal she's been
waiting for whether it was g5 sorry the
h4 d8 way to get the rook on e7 or the
a3 f8 way as soon as that threat happens
black is really under the gun because
this rook can't safely leave the seventh
rank with moves like rook back to e8 but
for a number of reasons one the pawn on
f7 is it's only a matter of time before
it comes under fire but here there's
actually a simple move like Queen a4 and
White's gonna start gobbling up things
if black is just in a position where he
has nothing nothing better than to just
play tickle gobbling a7 followed by
gobbling b6 is gonna create a new
problem for black principle of two
weaknesses the a file and the a pawn
becoming a queen will make black also
hurt for the fact that his pieces are
stuck on the Kings side so um after rook
d5 Queen H a queen before stockfish does
exactly what he had in mind man that you
see from the initial evaluation why
can't I just put the knight on c5
haven't I finally worked my way out of
this mess not so fast rook takes c5 I
call it a double X clam called a single
X clam call it just an exchange sac that
to all of us makes sense given the way
this game is gon be take c5 the key
point is not that you're taking back on
c5 ok this would allow a move like d6
and finally that d7 pawn that has been
crippled the whole game gets to move to
protect the rook and black is probably
in a position where some freedom can
happen here I think White's compensation
is still really tricky but but the it's
not nearly as clear as it could be the
idea is we're not taking back there
we're playing Queen h4 hitting the rook
again the rook cannot move off of the
seventh rank because f7 falls with
devastating effects and after the rook
is guarded finally the brilliant idea
that almost becomes full circle on
blacks initial problems in this Queen's
Indian pawn sac right pieces being
cramped and kind of stuck over here on
the Queen side to the position we now
have where the Queen is completely
frozen on AJ just amazing I take a look
at the theme we've been talking about
with black really feeling like he was
just strangled and didn't have a lot of
moves as soon as he thinks he's getting
some freedom and white has to give up
the exchange it gets worse the rook on
e7 is stuck the Queen on h8 is
nothing can really move here besides the
pawns and that's kind of what happens
after the Queen comes to f4 only ganging
up on f7 still everybody and their
cousin is is stuck to guarding this
weakness on f7 or the king
what I said is Shu literally we're down
to pawn moves black is gonna push some
pawns do what computers do best just
kind of push the pawns forward till we
run out of moves I note that a move like
rook d4 is never possible due to several
versions of maple and I'm gonna show you
my favorite one because there's a rook
takes f7 rook takes f4 and rook g7
double check and mate pretty darn sexy
right so that's that's a reason why that
rook can never leave only a few more
moves a matter of technique the pawn
comes to a3 after Queen f3 you really
see that black is running out of time
once the a3 pawn falls if black just
sits any further call it rook c8 or some
run the seventh rank the Queen will come
back to f3 and this continued battery on
f7 followed by the new problem of
rushing the a pawn up the board is
enough for black to just resign so
stockfish seeing the writing on the wall
so to speak finally decides he needs to
do something to get activity as
computers do probably a human would have
already resigned and just gives up the
Queen the rest is a a matter of
technique not sure if alpha zero really
speaks Russian schoolboy but if he does
he did show some pretty darn good
Soviets cool technique here the game is
over at game 3 was in the books and with
that the chess world turned upside down
please stay tuned for the rest of the
the games in this series of course we're
gonna be bringing and bringing you all
of our favorites with as much
instructive commentary as we can this is
what happens when two titans of the
chess world coming from the Silicon
Valley angle meet and congratulations to
alpha 0 for taking game 3 vs. stockfish
in their match